I'm thinking is the enemy of man it's
the destructor of man once you get so
and once you start giving yourself
obstacles what if I do lose you're just
lost yeah you just lost yeah but it's
amazing that people think they're really
gonna get ahead in this life without
making sacrifices it drives me crazy you
don't get smart by reading of Vogler
reading about Nostradamus you get smart
by family leave motivation what to top
ten we believe nation what's up believe
nation is Evan my one word is believe
and I believe in you I believe you have
Michael Jordan level talent at something
and I want you to find it embrace it and
use it to make a difference so let's get
your motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
in today's lessons from a man who went
from being born in Cuba losing his
father at age three coming home at age
15 and finding his mother dead in his
house going to jail eventually for
kidnapping and robbery to eventually
becoming a successful comedian he's Joey
Diaz and here's my take on his top ten
rules of success enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one stop thinking start doing everybody
growing up wants you to write that you
know we all want to do the right thing
you know was I I think the day I made
the decision to become a comedian I let
everything go that was a dead stop
thinking about things that wasn't there
stop worrying about bills that was there
stop worrying about what day it was it
doesn't really matter you have a mission
to do shut the [ __ ] up get up go do it
and that's it thinking is the enemy of
man
it's the destructor of man once you get
so and once you start giving yourself
obstacles what if I do lose you just
lost yeah absolutely
you just lost yeah what if I did well if
I try I don't like it okay you know what
yeah you just said the word if I try it
I don't like it you already committed
out of it you're out of there in three
weeks just because you said that just
because you relied your mind to go there
you just quit already
through some nuts in the last three
weeks seven last three weeks I think it
when I came to Iowa I had nothing to
lose I had nowhere to go
I was just a comment I ended up to
Seattle with a stripper and I thought
the goal of coming I know coming to LA
meant you had to be the best of the best
of the best in your field and it didn't
mean that just coming here makes you a
better person in a way absolutely lish
level and then once you get here it's
like anything else you would that and
adjust is that the word and you've run
with the ball like you know what you're
doing even though you don't know that
was what it was for me I ran with the
ball even though I did not know what was
going on rule number two sacrifice I
don't think people especially people
like Lee know it sacrifices sacrifice is
a big word to get to the next level I
don't give a what anybody tells you you
have a mom mmm
Steve's a mom yeah does your mom alive
yes thank you I should dad
thank God you have your brothers your
siblings yeah whether they live 3,000
miles away
that's sacrifice absolutely you don't
need this you don't need on the mother
that to be sitting between a Jew and a
Cuban getting tormented North Hollywood
California to go to the county store to
pick up a check for $15 absolutely your
parents man your grandparents migrated
here to this country for you to be a
better fit yeah your brother became a
dentist I'm not putting your dad right
not saying this but you sacrifice
absolutely you slept with faith James
and this apartment smelling his fat feet
is that for half here which were worse
than those Jews on the blame I have a
bar I just a bus for six years our Vice
sacrifices morally jobs a hole for
Christmas
yeah and I'm working at a Hollywood gym
my night shift it bothers me that nobody
understands that I always sacrificed
yeah I made the biggest sacrifice I
looked at a five-year-old little girl
one day in the park and I told her that
I'm really thinking you're going away
for a while that I think it would be
better and she spit in my face my
daughter my daughter at 27 years old Wow
well I told her about my dream she spit
in my face on a bicycle and that was to
pick a sacrifice I mean I made the
sacrifice to say I'll give up my
daughter to do something with my life
and I didn't go to weddings and I didn't
go to wakes and I didn't do a lot of
things yeah and I'm sure I'm sure along
the way I disappointed a lot of people
yeah because I didn't attend their
wedding or whatever function they had
because they had a party after I got off
the coke like in 2009 before I married
Terry is where this came this picture
became clearer to me that I even had a
sacrifice more hmm like I had a
sacrifice more like I went to Weight
Watchers I joined the karate with the
brothers in 2007 I was going that I was
I was four I was 380 when I walked in
there I'm ignoring horse stances and my
knees would burn they would make you do
these dragon stances where you drag one
foot and kneel on this one I don't have
to go home and put two bags of nice on
my knees but I knew that these were
little sacrifices I had to get make to
get to where one of the beat but it's
amazing that people think
they're really gonna get ahead in this
life without making sacrifices it drives
me crazy
yeah it drives me crazy rule number
three stick to your principles had some
dude stroking me he wanted to do some TV
show and the pitch and then he brought
he introduced me to the investors and
the investors dwarfs are gonna be in the
episode so I'm like oh this is gonna
blow then I had these other dudes who
wanna do an MMA show then I had these
other dudes who will they do a web
series and they had the dudes from the
social network yeah you know it was all
[ __ ] they had nothing you know I'm
saying that one day I'm sitting like oh
you don't want that's it
I'm not doing nothing no I'm not even
going to meetings with them I'm not even
gonna meet them if I don't see a
breakdown I'm not doing I'm not doing
that's it I'm sticking to my guns and I
break down there's the listing of the
yes in the next 90 days every week
hi Joey we had this thing we're doing
about mobsters no hey Joey
we have how much nothing it's just I bet
they're not not not not no forget it
cut the fatty and you know what happened
Lee I held up a year and AD nothing
really big happen in my life an awesome
one day I got a shout coke or to be in a
De Niro movie so me holding out showed
me that that's what you do sometimes
against your own because once you make a
law for yourself you have to stick to it
the first time you go away from that you
gotta get me ass it always happens the
first time you T like if you say to
yourself you know what my rates gonna be
650 650 650 and some guys come to see
well how about six that's the day you
give how about I give you 6 on a Sunday
and you're like okay I take the 6 of a
Sunday BAM that's the day you give
anything that changes your original
train of thought rule number four find
happiness
just the last 15 minutes of this podcast
was so strong from Monday morning about
like where it all starts with your mind
people don't really believe that but
it's true really for me it started when
I said I'm getting into comedy
I'm gonna give I'm on my credit bureau I
don't give a about the credit card
people I don't you about the bank's
about what I Drive give about what my
clothes on because at the end it doesn't
really matter unless you're happy for
years I worried about my channel Robin
I gotta have white sneakers or nothing I
have a black shirt on it who gives up at
the end of the day I wasn't happy I
wasn't happy I didn't get happy till I
started driving cross-country with a
pair of shorts on and stinky sneakers
and the t-shirt and you got three pair
of jeans and three shirts and they're
lasting you all week dog you got like
four pair of socks and you get on a
stage you good that's what I really
started getting happy when I started
waking up in the morning and knew I had
to drive 200 miles and I had 30 to 50 in
quarters and I had to get lunch with
that reefer and gas to get me that next
location for some reason I'd be happy a
lot happier than making 1,200 a week and
paying my bills I was like this is what
I like I like this oh it's food for
thought sometimes it's not about the
money or the dollars it's about what
brings a smile to your face and once you
find it let yourself go no you ain't
about it don't look back yeah don't
compare prices yeah don't listen to your
uncle about taking that roofing job for
1254 stability yeah you know what
stability is overrated don't stabilities
over it absolutely I think happiness is
doing what you want to the health and
even in there bro buddy I was in Cali
for
I was in comedy for 12 years before I
saw a dime yeah we were getting paid but
nothing to write home about I could have
quit at any time in those 12 years and
found the job I would had tricked
somebody into being an indoor salesman I
didn't want to do that I would have
rather live on eight thousand a year and
do my own thing and around at night and
smoke pot with your stupid buddies and
get on stage and going to an office
insurance who gives a [ __ ] when you
think about the insurance that's when
you need insurance for 30 years I ran
around with no insurance that never
happened to me rule number five take
little steps we can how good my day was
today in jujitsu I got there five to ten
I warmed up
it's a jumping jacks and push-ups I did
some bridges I've got a few hip escapes
that's long at V Mac it's a long thing I
got my guard like with John beat me up
and he passed my god every time every
time didn't submit me buddy past my
guard every day it is the beauty of it
here's on my conscience my boy he passed
my guard and I move my legs oh my god
I'm a half guard basically all the times
towards the end when Henry got there I
wanted to deep F and I went the wrong
direction but in my world
whatever deep path I wouldn't have done
that six months ago I don't even know
how it worked and guess what I threw his
balance off for me that's a start I
thought do you understand me yeah of
course and you have to do the same thing
with comedy or anything like that you
have to take little accomplishments and
not lose your mind when you do get a big
accomplishment yeah look at it and
perspective like okay this is why that
happened at least I know it can happen
again if it happens again I'm a bad man
you know but ever had no and that's like
that's like you know for comic okay I
come to see this really happened to me
Eddie this really happened to me
some guy used to give me a lot of work
cool I still talk to him this is back in
Denver 25 23 years ago this guy used to
give me work and when they called me up
he got me a gig one night and before
going on stage I gonna do he knew I
worked on him every day you know your
students could do you see him every day
he goes through 15 you know and this is
1995 I've been doing comedy for years I
was struggling to do 15 16 I would
struggle ready this the one outside of
some chick he was but he was supposed to
give me a light at 12 but he won't have
a start of some chick
I just kept already I just kept going
and I had him and he came back in and he
wanted he gave me the light and then
when I got off he goes way everything
goes dogs I'm sorry chick you ended up
doing 38 minutes I couldn't sleep that
night because I never dreamt her doing
38 minutes but I did it do you know I'm
saying if you leak aim to me into Joey
I'm gonna bind do 20 I would have choked
I was a straight-up chump but since
there was no clock in my mind yeah
that's when I knew you know I'm sorry
little I went home that night I almost
call CA CBS and supplier Dave Letterman
last night in Denver I swear the guy
you're walking so high it's such a big
accomplishment it's such a big
accomplice are the ones that keep you in
the game okay I did 38 I'll do it enough
for a year you bomb you can't do 30 you
just bump but eventually if you just
stick it hotdog you're gonna make you
know it was it's a nightmare but it's so
much fun
rule number six learn from failures you
learn from failure you learn from
getting hit in the pocket you know you
learn something getting hit in the
pocket you follow me
when you're giving somebody half your
money you gotta sell your house and you
like I'm
mistake next time I'm gonna play a
little closer to my chest that's how you
learn in life it's not by reading a book
because you're not gonna listen to read
the heart of war is going to teach you
how to or the war of art isn't teach who
had a plan and strategize or both how to
get rid of your fears or whatever but
it's not gonna tell you what to do and
what not to do what's a mistake and
what's not a mistake
nobody knows through the tool you think
Kenny Rogers well he invested in that
chicken company he thought that no you
know they came to him with a deal go to
know until you try it you know get smart
by him breathing of vocal reading about
Nostradamus you get smart by family and
then you decide what you're not gonna do
no more I won't be doing that no more
yes I will number seven being control of
your career I really didn't have anybody
taking me on the road I remember I would
work with certain people but I would
never ask them to take me on the road
there were a few people who did take me
on the road but unlike Jordan and Rick
turns but I always knew that I didn't
want to be that guy I knew that I wanted
to always be able to do my own thing not
just to sit at home and wait for that
beck and call deal him saying like
that's the type of person that I wanted
to be like I was still at the comedy
store and I was still I did all those
Mexican rooms in South LA every single
one of them every night a week that's
what pays of my addiction but at the
same time not knowing I was also
becoming a better comedian because I
would go into deep terrain four nights a
week and then go to the comedy store
everything is hunky-dory you follow me
you know this there's places where he
people come prepared to left and there's
places but it's a bar and you gotta go
up there and blow your toe off to get
their attention rule number eight find
your path I went to prison before I got
locked up there was a guy til I did not
like too much when I worked with him we
didn't like each other
and
one day this guy came up to me and he
goes you know you don't think I like ya
if I won't offer you like me or whatever
I'm along this straight side he goes do
you know what I did before I retired it
took this job as a sales manager and I
go no this is two weeks before I got
locked up to wish before I locked up he
does when I got arrested in bold I was
we're gonna bill crowd Subaru but 28th
Street this was it was on 28th Street
grant that was the guy's name god bless
his soul I had worked there and he
didn't like my style was selling he
didn't like that I was like a sandwich
and he came up to my leg as I'm wearing
it so I just stayed away from ya about a
week later he came on to me it was a do
you know what I did before I they does I
was the Booker for more that's just seen
on surveying us I think I'm so got to
tell you you might have a career as a
stand-up comic and I've lifted them like
are you [ __ ] are you crazy
then I got arrested thought went right
out the window
like it wasn't threatened until my
little girl at the house wasn't even a
thought damn they think if I couldn't
even say you know what you should play
the harmonica yeah okay I got in the car
and I wouldn't got that right now you
think about it that baggage it was it
was that crazy to you it like it was
like the harmonica like you you you
wouldn't even consider saying me comedy
and go you know what leave a large you
should play the boat like you know I
don't want this drove a Hollywood Bowl
I'll hook you up connection down there
that's so I just got my
I got arrested went to a process ended
up at Camp George West and golden when I
was in there what happened and they were
always in the kitchen no in the kitchen
when I was a stock clerk and I was
around with the black inmates yeah if
the food wasn't good I go don't do it
yeah I yell across this to think the
brothers would be teller I go like this
to you don't do and they go god damn it
we got to eat reserves again cuz they
all had food their rooms yeah so one day
the projector broke and I would go
onstage they would go to Cuba God
something happened that they said Tom
what happened today like it was one of
those things so I'll tell you what
happened mr. Yarborough by that wasn't a
good storyteller something like that and
then like a week later they said the
projector broke illegal Cuba QWOP dead
crack silly jokes and this went on for
about four or five weeks so it's kind of
your first open my money the black guys
they were stealing junkies what's in the
no material working a crowd Theriot just
working it straight black Mexican white
look at this dude watch out they're
looking for entertainment and they all
dug me and they all got along man never
had any beef and then it was his white
dude from Buffalo children's wife and
her boyfriend and he was at the end of a
23-year beat and then he had to go to
Buffalo on a survey he is and he rolled
his own cigarettes he was very nerdy
about every book he would get the deep
arguments about Nietzsche with everybody
and I've been throwing that every day
and after cuz my job was very limited my
job was like two hours an hour and a
half and I had the rest of the day off
to about 4:30 so I'm little library and
read the paper the sports page and I
returned a book and when they bro he
came up to me to give me a notebook
which is big in jail like together a
notebook you know small hardcover ones
yeah don't look like you took a hit of
acid they're black on white and then
it's his name and subject now like it
was one of those and he goes tape this
and I go why and he goes so you can
write your jokes like he was like tell
like I just got killed his wife and the
guy that was cheating on him with
mr. smart was up to me when a nobody
just take this because you're gonna need
this you should write a jump on it like
he was happy he gave me surfing I'll
never forget and I go what's this for
you'll see can write your jokes man he
goes you did really good last week I
mean I'm not a comedian I just go up
there around and he looked at me like
you know for wait a second when you go
up there on Thursdays you not prepared
I don't know wonderful you see me right
now come on you're right yeah and he
goes laughing man when you got out of
jail you should try this rule number
nine make no excuses I'll talk to you
the balls in your court
no more around you want your life to be
better I can't help you Lee can't help
you Joe Rogan can't help you already
can't help you God can't help you
only you could help you grab your balls
get a notebook and write down what the
you're gonna do this year and this is it
you're not gonna have these problems to
drugs to cigarettes that dump it all
starts today all right no more excuses
stop blaming everything on everybody and
American society in my father's do you
enough an iPhone G with Facebook's
key with social media it's all about you
you dumb get up grab your balls hug your
wife kiss the kids pick up the dog stop
it stop it it's not all Obama's fault
you don't want a bowler take your
vitamin C dump you know what I system
you stay in New Jersey but stop your
crying and rule number 10 the last time
before a very special bonus clip is
perform amazingly nice to live in
Hollywood I never see nobody you can see
you know whatever these creepy people
but you don't really understand like
onto you like I moved to North Hollywood
now I understand that Mexican Cuban but
I never understood the Mexican like to
this and all the way to the root you
understand me and you talk to people by
mixing what they tell you brother who
the take off a job no they're not
they're here to make your life easier
okay tonight you need some food you know
I'm saying
you know wake up you know we can put a
headache and hair in your throat gonna
be missing you know it's Sunday if
you're a real tonight that's how it is
tomorrow morning you wake up there's a
stranger next to you you got condoms
everywhere a knife in your side you
can't breathe you're thirsty
you wash your face you brush it you need
something to drink right so right away
you want to get like the nourishment
back so you're driving I mentor with a
you live and you see Jamba Juice and I
got to cut somebody off and go in there
wait some guy comes out with 22 Jamba
Juice's you know the whole thing you
gotta go in then you know and then it's
done mate
this is supposed to be a healthy place
everybody's pale you like the cast and
Twilight they're all skinny is hi can I
help you I just want something drink Bow
Wow I'm saying I want some vitamins for
50 cents we got vitamin D how much $12
$12 you give they got a ticket you gotta
go yeah ah with a blender you gotta wait
a minute you're almost dead they give
you the thing and you're drinking you go
you got a $92 ticket cuz you can't park
there from 10:00 to 1:00 okay
so cost you $100 from gyro whatever
these Jamba Juice you know with the
castor Twilight a bunch of unhealthy
skinny money but living on 5-hour energy
and other nutrients you want to juice
that back they're texting like a bunch
of hobos on their iPhone I don't got an
iPhone I got a gun are you understand my
jumbo juice
ah ah you go to the Mexican guy and
victory and violent right by target
right there
nevertheless do these dark does he's
been out there for years you understand
me
they're in a tree out there this you
know if he's black what the dog
you're gonna par just pull right there
you can double Park with your ass
sticking out of target they don't give
up you go out there you like Lewis and
Brahms so I want some of the drinking
moves coconuts he'll take one of them
coconuts out and taking Miceli out right
there on victory environment spy away
put a show on it with some cocaine on
the top of it you're like how much four
dollars four dollars
take charge you got a sword for dollars
I could drop a hundred and Jamba Juice
for four hours it's Mexico give me a
tree a shovel a blow I take a Jamba
[Music]
now I've got two really special bonus
clips from Joey on how to practice
martial arts and keep going that I think
you're gonna really enjoy but before
that it's time for the three point
landing questions time to move from
watching a video to actually taking
action in your life or your business so
answer these three questions at home in
your notebook talk about them with a
friend or leave your replies in the
comments below here we go question
number one what does happiness look like
for you question number two what little
step can you take today to move closer
to happiness and question number three
what's the biggest lesson you've learned
from past failures thank you guys so
much for watching I believe in you I
hope we continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon and enjoy the bonus
clips
the reality of jiu-jitsu is it's a thing
that as you get older you have to be
much more careful who you train with and
how you train I love it
you know addicted to it it's trying to I
am you know I had a tacit from a
different foundation I was attacking it
from looking at Jamie and going I gotta
do what Jamie does and not realize that
I got Jamie by twenty five years and I
can't do what Jamie does so my game has
to be completely different in Jamie's
Mondays when I come into class it's more
about their the drilling mm less about
the role and how do our conditioning
class with Brett we do everything we do
the ball the things the ropes
I do everything and I'll do that
jiu-jitsu class but I'll do the drills
I'll roll once or twice and Papa's gotta
go Thursday I go balls to the wall on
the roaming which means three or four
rolls that's awesome and then I try to
take Friday off and then sat out the
movie tying condition and I'm done for
the week Joey Diaz getting fit you gotta
do it it's a beautiful day you got the
world by the ball you're young man 55 I
got one foot in the grave one a banana
peel and I'm still swaying I come on
you're sitting there thinking your world
is over you've got it yeah I said the
word I don't give a uncle Joey's
periscope is not politically correct if
you're under 18 hang up now your dirty
little anyway this is the best nation in
the world you sitting there what am I
gonna do I got more problem can of
psychotherapy pills bullying today some
every morning you gotta get a fight you
own listen even if you fake you go out
there and fake the funk until you get
the funk you follow me I'm not even
listen I'm not even talking about the
bridge I cross cross as a comic I'm
talking about the bridge that I crossed
as a human being you know I'm saying
where I was and where I am today it's
two different places and if I did it you
could do it I got PTSD the Mack you
don't see me talking about it I don't
know what coming from all directions I'm
worse than a football player but you
know what
and I spoke my reefa I calm the voices
down and every day I get up with two
hands and I play for keeps and that's
all I do
that's it and you if I could do it and
I'm felling left back in the seventh
grade Jean can you imagine what you
could do with a family and a little good
smile and I got a bellyful smile raise
your standard Apple at the core its core
value is that that people need passion
and not one drop of my self-worth
depends on your that's something to me
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten roses success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link the description for details